good I was actually heading home it has
not been my best day so I'm gonna take a
bath I moved a TV in there so I can
watch movies that's cool you live in the
dream I love that for you
um
that was a clip from Apple's new dramedy
series shrinking about a widowed
therapist struggling to be there for his
daughter friends and patients one of the
show's creators is Brett Goldstein a
breakout star from Apple's emmy-winning
series Ted lasso virtually unknown to
American audiences before taking on the
role of Roy Kent he became an overnight
sensation but as we found out when we
caught up with him a few weeks ago the
42 year old british-born writer actor
and stand-up comedian has been
entertaining audiences since childhood
today you will play like a bunch of
little pricks you hear me yes
yes Roy Kent the foul-mouthed and Gruff
aging footballer turned coach in Apple
TV's Ted lasso my eyebrows crazy who's
quirkiness and colorful language you
just have someone who makes you feel
like you've been struck by lightning
combined with moments of compassion this
isn't embarrassing have made for a
character that's embraced on screen and
off I'm guessing you can't walk down the
street easily without somebody yelling
perhaps a curse word in your direction
sure sure that's the same as ever yeah
Brett Goldstein who earned two Emmy
Awards for his portrayal of Kent you
him up as we found during our
interview shares a proclivity for
colorful language with the character I
mean it's it's a great part he's a great
character right guys but his affinity
for Kent goes well beyond language
nabbing the part in a way Hollywood
might script it you were hired as a
writer yeah and you knew Roy Kent yeah
was the part for you yeah because I felt
it so powerfully like a colleague but I
also I knew that chances were minimal to
none so I sent this self-type on that
last day and I said if you hate this
pretend you never got it
but what I had to lose I guess was if it
was embarrassing and awkward for them
maybe I wouldn't get us back to write
season two so I did have something to
lose right but I also was just like I've
got to do this it's the same attitude
and admittedly offbeat Goldstein had as
a kid growing up in Sutton England
obsessed with films and Drawn to
performing do you remember the First
shows you were in like theater plays
doing places
oh yeah yeah yeah I played Mrs fox in
Fantastic Mr Fox
maybe I was six seven eight uh as you
got older if I mean it's one thing as a
kid to say this is what I want to do
did you have any hesitation of can I
make a living at this
I just I I think because and that's one
of the reasons I wrote I was always
writing is that my plan was always I'll
make something so it'll just
it'll have to happen because I'm writing
scripts I've writing books writing films
I just never had a backup plan
challenge himself even further
Dean added stand up to his creative
Outlet
all right lovely it's lovely to be here
it was like a support group I was like
I'm not getting any younger I do it once
and I won't tell anyone I've done it and
then I can tell my grandkids I did it
and then I'll die and I did it
and it was amazing no some of you were
probably thinking what the hell happened
to the second act he's grown I know it
was like alive for five minutes I was
like bang bang bang incredible I was
thinking if he and me and Richard stood
there it'd be like the evolution of man
and I then booked as many gigs I gigged
every single night and I died for two
years I was just gonna say it couldn't
have gone well yeah listen when it's bad
it's the worst there's nothing worse but
when it's good
and you connect it is Magic is it
nerve-wracking when you're getting ready
for a show or looking at the greatest
comedians of all time yes
yes but Goldstein still can't get enough
playing small venues in both the UK and
the states juggling stand up between his
list of growing projects like Apple TV's
recently launched comedy series
shrinking starring Harrison Ford nobody
gets through this life unscathed and
Jason Siegel hello here are my bushes I
really everyone kept is it topiary is
that what that's called I don't know
Jimmy some guy doesn't Goldstein served
as co-creator executive producer and
writer I got you fresh blueberries for
your morning oats because I know you
love your oats even though nobody really
loves oats because they taste like wet
paper you have this father and the
daughter and he has thoroughly failed
her at the beginning of this show I
think it's interesting trying to repair
that and also
the idea of how do you re-establish the
dynamic of a father and daughter when
she has been the parent
how can she allow you back into the
position of dad and I've been dealing
with it on my own because I had to so
please don't think that blueberries and
washing a shirt
is enough to make me forgive you for all
of that
people make mistakes and do bad things
and the idea of how can you move past
those things is interesting even the way
describing this and yet I'm going to say
and it's a comedy yeah it's very funny
it's really funny it's really funny you
know the characters are really
interesting
Goldstein credits Ted lasso for opening
doors for him like with shrinking and
some a little more unexpected like his
foray into Marvel Comics as Hercules yes
Father
and what Goldstein calls his ultimate
role they're all different types of
gangs like suckers on Sesame Street he
is never going to find us
was that talking Trey the Sesame Street
was the best day of my life hands down
there's no disrespect to all the people
that I've loved right
I was thinking about that I was like
What if I ever have a baby I know and
I'll say to the baby the day you were
born was great but have you met
[Laughter]
you found us the joy if not magic
Goldstein says he found at Sesame Street
a feeling he compared to what's been
created on the set of Ted lasso and
while he was quick to point out it's not
his decision if this spring season three
is indeed the last one if it is will you
miss Roy Kent yeah
I would sincerely miss it I think we all
will you just can't believe that we'll
have that an experience like that
regardless of how things are received
forget all that right regardless whether
you'll have another show that is a
success that doesn't matter in terms of
the
love onset and how much
we really love to tell you guys I hope
whatever I do has that again but you
think it feels rare
shrinking is now streaming on Apple TV
Plus in season three of Ted lasso
expected to premiere on the streaming
service this spring I've watched nine of
ten episodes of shrinking it actually is
funny I know you're wondering how that
dramedy uh part how it works it's funny
I also have to say Breck Goldstein Loves
Movies he has a podcast he's a
fascinating guy loved every second of
that interview I watched two episodes of
shrinking Harrison Ford is greatest it's
so funny he's so funny in it